im studio begrüße ich den ukrainischen
botschafter in deutschland ein remake
schönen guten abend gut nacht platin die
klitschkos sagen ganz klar ihn gerade
auch in diesem interview nach sieben
wochen krieg tragen wir weiterhin die
harten konsequenzen die harten
konsequenzen die der westen eigentlich
angekündigt hat doch wir tragen die
harten konsequenzen und auch im
bundestag heute das thema man hat
gesehen parteienübergreifend alle haben
ihre solidarität bekundet alle haben
gesagt sie stehen der ukraine bei
dennoch zu diesem zeitpunkt sind das für
sie volle worte empfinden sie diesen
beistand deutschlands als ausreichend
also wir hoffen dass dass die
bundesregierung sich endlich dazu
entschließt auch das embargo für den
importstopp von öl gas und nicht nur
kohle wie angekündigt dass das dieser
maßnahmen eingeführt werden denn wir
haben jetzt zusammen gezählt seit dem
kriegsbeginn wurde seitens der eu knapp
35 milliarden euro an andy butenschön
armee gezahlt für energielieferungen und
die ukraine hatte knapp eine medaille
bekommen was was die wahl von angeht und
das ist nämlich die revolution das heißt
putin für diesen krieg und wenn er weiß
dass die deutschen so abhängig hier
bleiben und wenn sie wissen dass die
regierung zögert diesen schritten zu
unternehmen dann kann er ruhig jetzt
versuchen half einzunehmen und die
gleichen daten zu verüben oder verüben
zu lassen wie jetzt wieder in butter
gesehen haben präsident seinen ski sagte
im deutschen bundestag ist zugeschaltet
war sagte er es gehe deutschland
offenbar viel um die wirtschaft
wirtschaft wirtschaft dass uns die
wirtschaft wichtiger ist die menschen
also uns scheint schon diese debatte ein
bisschen verrückt zu sein ehrlich gesagt
weil
wir gar nicht wissen was noch mehr
geschehen sollte oder welche weitere
massaker wir erleben sollten um einfach
dann diese nächste rote linie zur zu
sehen und endlich zu handeln wir glauben
schon dass das auch die bundesregierung
also die geschichte die den menschen
hier im lande erzählt wird dass die
wirtschaft kollabieren würde dass die
rezession
ungeheure maßstäbe erreichte das dass
das einfach die gesamte wirtschaft
zusammenbricht fast ja so hat man den
eindruck also wir haben auch andere
analysen gesehen von von deutschen
unabhängigen wirtschaftsinstituten die
wir sagen ja das wird treffen auch die
die deutschen auch die bundesrepublik
aber nicht in dem ausmaß fast
apokalyptischen wie das klingt und
deswegen haben wir schon das dass man
bereit sein sollte diesen mutigen
schritt mutigen schritt für für die
menschen auch zu unternehmen zumindest
für einen 23 monate also ein moratorium
für für die viele lieferungen von
energieträger aus russland und da glaube
ich wird herr putin seinen appetit auf
diesen schrecklichen krieg verlieren
lassen sie uns gemeinsam auf ein foto
blicken das heute entstanden ist und
zwar in vilnius in litauen das ist eine
protestaktion vor der deutschen
botschaft
dort sehen sie die menschen liegen und
sie wollen aufmerksam machen auf wunsch
und dass dieser protest soll er offenbar
aussagen auch deutschland trägt schuld
an dem massaker von butscher sehen sie
das auch so
ich glaube dass jede der
geldströme in die kriegskasse von hand
boden fließen lässt kann nicht ohne
schuld bleiben herunter ich glaube dass
das die bundesregierung sich doch fragen
sollte wie wird diese situation von
heute diese strecken die wir in buschehr
in anderen vororten krebs aber leider
gottes wahrscheinlich auch in mariupol
die russen nur da sind da gibt es keine
journalisten da gibt es kein paul
ronzheimer der da ist aufgeklärt sondern
das wird alles verschleiert und deswegen
glaube ich schon dass das dieses gefühl
ja wie wird deutschland auf diese
dramatischen tage zurückblicken wird man
auch ein reines gewissen haben oder wird
es doch ein 1 1 ein gefühl sein hätten
wir vielleicht doch was unternehmen
müssen um solche solche
verbrechen kriegsverbrechen verbrechen
gegen die menschlichkeit oder sogar
vielleicht auf völkermord zu verhindern
dass wir glaube ich die frage sein wie
heute sich noch nicht stellt weil man
mag man macht sich sorgen um den
wohlstand wir haben ja immer wieder
gehört wollen stand wohlstandsverluste
das sind so die hauptsorgen und ich
glaube aus dieser perspektive der
geschichte sollte man sich vorstellen
wie das aussieht deswegen also ich bin
persönliche fest davon überzeugt dass
das die einzig moralisch richtige
antwort auf diese verbrechen sein könnte
dass man dass man diese scharfen
sanktionen sofort einführt und nicht
mehr weiter zögert hätte ein schneller
deutscher gasstopp butscher verhindern
können ich glaube schon also ich bin
davon überzeugt obwohl manche sagen aber
woher sollen wir wissen dass das dieser
sofortige importstopp weil sie ihn dazu
bringt sein sein seine vernichtungskrieg
zu beenden habe ich meine jeden tag
knapp eine milliarde euro alleine durch
durch die energielieferungen bekommt
herr putin und sein
verteidigungsministerium dafür um diesen
krieg weiter anzuheizen und zu befeuern
und deswegen ich glaube diese frage
sollte man sich aus gewissensgründen
aber auch ganz moralisch schon stellen
ein krieg der bilder in die welt bringt
bilder wie dieses dass wir ihnen zeigen
wollen es ist ein bild das die ganze
welt bewegt hat das war noch am montag
unsere große titelseite erfahren sie
hier die traurige geschichte hinter
diesem foto
die hand einer frau aus der hölle von
butscher ihre leiche liegt würdelos im
straßendreck die roten fingernägel eine
erinnerung an frühere zeiten friedliche
zeiten roter lack rund um ein herz auf
dem mittelfinger
beschmiert mit schmutz
jetzt wissen wir wer der mensch war
hinter dem schrecklichen foto ihr name
irena
irena die hier mit ihrem hund spielt
ganz schwach können wir ihr lachen hören
[Musik]
fotos vom instagram account ihrer
tochter zeigen eine sympathische frau
mit sonnigem lächeln bin ich jetzt
erwachsen mama fragt ihrer tochter olga
in ihrer ins tor du warst mir immer eine
helfende hand meine freunde nennen dich
immer noch mutter ihrer eine hand die
stützt die tränen wegwischte eine hand
die jetzt vielen ukrainischen kindern
helfen soll holger hat in ihre maßnahmen
einen gedenk von eröffnet um geld für
die kinder der ukraine zusammen
das hätte mama ihre als sicher gefallen
eine frau die auch unsere mutter sein
könnte meine frau die jeder von uns sie
als nachbarin haben
[Musik]
eine frau wie wir sie täglich auf der
straße treffen könnten aber jetzt nicht
mehr
irena kann niemanden mehr treffen
[Musik]
andrej melik der botschafter der ukraine
hier noch zu gast sind diesen beitrag
haben wir gemeinsam verfolgt es ist sehr
schwer da die tränen zurückzuhalten was
geht ihnen durchs herz wenn sie das
sehen ja
das ist das ein schicksal das jetzt
hunderttausende menschen erreicht hat
und das schlimmste dass auch so viele
kinder jetzt waisen geworden sind so
viele kinder gar nicht wissen was mit
den eltern geschehen ist und aber auch
so viele kinder
auch missbraucht wurden wir haben viele
butscher ist nur jetzt ein schreckliches
beispiel dessen
von den spuren die buden und seine
schergen hinterlasst hinterlassen in
meine heimat aber wir müssen leider
befürchten dass auch andere ortschaften
die wir noch nicht besucht haben also
brillant ist das könnte der nächste
ordentlich strecken seien ein bisschen
nördlich von von von von butscher da
haben die russen besonders
besonders schlimm gewütet ja wir waren
schon dort hat er schon belegt das ja
und und also ich die bilder die die man
gesehen hat alleine die stadt wie sie
aussieht also
dass das da da da fehlen einfach die
worte und
ich glaube ich glaube schon dass die
politik ich meine wie lange kann man
hier in deutschland auch solche bilder
ertragen also wie lange kann man einfach
schauen und hoffen dass das man
irgendwie anders agieren kann man hat
beschlossen hier
ob zu recht oder nicht wird die
geschichte zeigen aber nicht zu
intervenieren militärisch das können das
können wir verstehen aber
wirtschaftlich betrachtet das und auch
die aussenministerin hat ja noch
am beginn des weges gesagt wir sind
bereit einen hohen wirtschaftlichen
preis dafür zu zahlen dass dieser krieg
zu ende gehen so schnell wie möglich und
jetzt ist der zeitpunkt gekommen erst
die zeit zu zeigen dass auch hier die
ampelkoalition
mutig agieren kann um neue bücher zu
verhindern wenn wir uns jetzt vorstellen
dass interaktiv alle kräfte und all die
mörder die kindesmörder die im norden
stationiert worden sie werden jetzt
abgezogen auf züge verladen
in belarus und richtung graf und meine
google geschickt ja diesen die gleichen
menschen die jetzt noch vor wenigen
wochen menschen zivilisten auf den
straßen
exekutiert haben
fahrradfahrer menschen die einfache
kartoffel holen wollten kaltblütig
erschossen auf der stelle und dann
werden sie jetzt irgendwo in einem dorf
von vorort von hgs erscheinen und dieses
um diese verbrechen vorsätzen ich glaube
man man man sollte sich besinnen darauf
wie die geschichte diese tage diese
woche urteilen wird und das ist glaube
ich etwas würde man sich durchaus
gedanken machen sollte auch in der
regierung was glauben sie wie viele
butchers gibt es noch also wir müssen
befürchten dass
dutzende offensichtlich hunderte solche
orte gegeben hat dann im süden des
landes wissen wir gar nicht oder nur
wenig was geschieht da wo die russen
schon seit dem ersten kriegstag viele
gebiete besetzt haben zwischen personen
und mario pohl das sind jetzt nicht nur
soldaten soldaten also männer in uniform
unterwegs sondern da sind auch schon fsb
leute geheimdienstler die aktivisten
aktivisten suchen die durchkämmen häuser
die menschen terrorisieren
dass der zelte auf meine kollegin ihr
vater leben im keller ohne funk ohne
wasser ohne strom ohne licht ohne
heizung seit dem essen krieg kriegstag
sein als in maria nein das ist nicht
weit von christen also das sind die
gebiete die noch am ehesten überrannt
wurden und und manchmal gibt es gar
keine verbindung über nachbarn und meine
kollegin weiß nicht gar nicht also
obwohl der vater noch lebt oder nicht
verschleppt wurde was mit ihm geschehen
ist und deswegen also dieser brutalität
dieser grausamkeit ist
präsident los also wir haben das seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg gar nicht
für möglich gehalten dass die menschen
so so brutal vorgehen können gegen
zivilisten gegen frauen und kinder die
nichts getan haben weil diese propaganda
maschinerie um das auch eine eine eine
ein appell an die bundesregierung bis
heute kann man all die staatlichen
sender des kreml hier in deutschland
empfangen im kabel in hotels aber auch
im internet bei youtube und das hat dazu
geführt dass diese gesellschaft in
russland genauso brutal und summiert
wurde dass menschen kein herz zu zu
haben scheinen wenn wie telefonate jetzt
abhören von diesem von diesen mördern
von von butscher dann berichten sie
ihren liebsten was zieht also gemacht
haben geplündert welche geschenke sie ja
mit mitschicken mitbringen wollen und da
scheint er gar kein kein mitgefühl zu
haben das heißt alles der kälte steckt
hin und und und das ist das produkt also
diese jahrelang einen propaganda sei
bequem annexion und dass das auch bis
heute auch in deutschland zu empfangen
ist das sind millionen menschen
die russische wurzeln haben und die
immer noch vielleicht zu hause nicht der
täter sondern eher dieser kanäle sich
ansehen und da müsste auch die politik
endlich etwas tun weil man kann ich
hoffe dass die russen jetzt plötzlich
erwachen wieso sollten sie es gibt
keinen zugang zum internet in einem
interview
der frankfurter allgemein zeitung sagen
sie alle russen sind jetzt die feinde
wie meinen sie das das klingt hart das
kann ich auch verstehen dass für für sie
für für viele unsere deutschen freunde
diese aussage kaum zu verkraften ist
denn man kann natürlich nicht
pauschalisieren man gar nicht alle
menschen quasi mit
bezeichnen als als feinde aber eins ist
klar für uns putin hat diesen krieg zwar
begonnen aber führt diesen krieg die
russische föderation als staat als volk
und das bedeutet dass solange dieser
krieg geführt wird es ist schwer
vorstellbar dass man dass man in irgend
etwas gemeinsames also mit mit dem
russischen solcher und das meint auch
die russen auch die menschen zu tun
haben möchte das ist ein gefühl das ist
schwer zu beschreiben vielleicht aber
für für uns und zwar nicht nur nach
diesem nachnamen wie diese bilder
gesehen sondern auch insgesamt es gibt
ein staat der versucht uns so zu
vernichten und deswegen muss man das aus
dieser perspektive sehen also jemand der
sich für sind wir nicht meister da gibt
es keine zwischentöne ergebnis leider
leider gottes für uns nur schwarz oder
weiß und das ist die realität eine
schreckliche realität in der wir seit 42
tagen leben müssen andrej melik
botschafter der ukraine hier in
deutschland vielen herzlichen danke
ihnen für das gespräch danke danke danke
schön